dans tes bras oublie ma peine c'est la
première chanson de michèle torr elle
était venue à chanter il ya quelques
mois elle est bien voulu vous lé el afia
voulu revenir jambes pas fouilles
je me mets à imiter les confrères dans
la boxe est pas possible qu est ce que
je disais qu'elle va chanter mais
richard michel torr la première chanson
quand elle avait 16 ans yeah yeah
[Musique]
on verra
m
je t'aime
[Musique]
viens je soigne
ton coeur blessé je veux tu es beau
[Musique]
il assène
quitte à quitter
il a fait chaud
[Musique]
ap
tu
je t'ai
[Musique]
tu ne vois que la petite amie de jeu
ton
[Musique]
oui
quimper
lee
[Musique]
tu
je donne
[Musique]
ne vont pas aux navires tout et 2
je ne
[Musique]
la demande
que je
temps
mais bon
et à peine
[Applaudissements]
paris
[Musique]
le temps
bonnet
[Musique]